the Joe Rogan experience when you in the
will say in the mid-80s the early
eighties if if you weren't a drinker you
were the exception the rule again Wow
so you weren't a drink it before not
really you just started hanging out with
these guys and wasn't that blame in any
of them oh no hey look I'm not even but
was it right away
like just each of what you walked into
this lion's den of people doing drugs
the [ __ ] whose patient zero
like who because it was wasn't that many
of you right well I think that I think
that it came to a culmination at the
thing hole because we basically ran and
owned the place and we'd stay there
until I can remember walking other than
many times going oh beautiful it's not
even laid out yet thirty in the morning
right but we were serving drinks and
half the people they'd be 1012 Communion
sitting around and and for fire of other
guys and the other guys are cops
they're in there drinking with this to
us so we weren't gonna get busted I mean
Kenny ridin first got there he walked in
the door there he got there I don't know
how but he got there around 2:00 in the
morning and there's six or seven of us
you know it's Mary the smoking joints
doing doing some wine drinking and more
up on their stage playing cards you know
for money good yeah
because someone said when he went for
taking us who was it healer drinka stand
your biggest nobody you I saw so the
Nate's getting to other stuff so any he
made up for lost time to that was what
we do we'd always heard about the ding
ho like it was like some legendary place
you know when we started out it closed
in like 84 or something maybe yeah right
around this time later I started in 88
and we had heard about the ding homes
like was spoken in hushed tones yeah it
was like you know that's where it
started well closed in a heartbeat
because the the owner lost lost the club
had playing Chinese Domino's no he lost
two hundred forty thousand dollars in
one night mmm and it was my night then I
had my show there on Fridays I'd come in
and I'd never saw chains of padlocks
bigger than that in the front
never to be reopened as a comedy club it
became a Indian restaurant that's up
there but it just went in Chinese Donny
what Chinese denials are that's BIC
probably God I mean it's it's crazy how
something like that can happen where
there is just this one place and one
core group of people and then the comedy
club scene branches out from that like
Houston used to have this place called
the laugh stop did you ever yeah that
was the same thing for Houston Houston
had a great used to mother little crazy
- yeah it was wild yeah yeah and when I
first went there it was when it was at
its wildest it was after Kinnison had
gone yeah
Bill Hicks had left and all those guys
were gone and yeah Calibos yeah yeah
yeah Jimmy pineapple Jimmy worked with
me the first time I ever did a week in
there and the first time I was ever
there I was like wow this place is like
a lot like Boston like early like seed a
bunch of wild [ __ ] they had to know
they had a show going on in the main
room and then in the bar area they had
another stage and the open mic night
started at 8:00 went until 2 o'clock in
the morning so you get done with your
show the show be over at 10:00 and you
go out to the bar and you'd be [ __ ]
hanging out there for another four hours
because the show still going on yeah it
was it was crazy because I made a good
stir they always we used to walk from
the hotel through the venue and I'm and
it was all they you know cowboy space to
sit down there and so I get I'm walking
I get hit in the back with the water
balloon but you would have thought it
was chef with a shrug by you but like a
rhino gun you know bang thing I was
soaking wet when I get there I had to
put them one of their t-shirts and I'm
going I can't believe how how this guy
hit me that could so Brian I get to the
club I see the car it was recognizable
anger they uh they kept coming to see me
so I went inside got a hammer and went
out during the show and the open air
event broke every window in their car
including the directionals the side and
I Carmen understandable
I so ever did it nobody took climb I
said what but what a great name yet and
but I didn't mention it about their car
that's hilarious
did you go out watch oh yeah check to
learn what they do
right I thought I brought those little
tiny you know directions on the side of
the car I mean in every window can
anybody can flatten it yes if you break
every single window that's that's an
accomplishment that is an accomplishment
and it's a lot of work to get that fixed
yeah what especially I'm with no
lookouts and I change a tire pretty good
yeah you know look outside
[Applause]